hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
[Music]
I'm just checking in on you I'm just
checking in on you you know you almost
through the week summer you get paid
today some of you don't I don't know how
it [ __ ] works but yeah I'm just here
to check in on you just for the [ __ ]
half an hour I hope you guys enjoyed the
very special edition of the Monday
morning podcast that was put out
yesterday with the great the great Jim
Norton promoting his new stand-up
special that you can watch now on
Netflix mouthful of shame I've heard
nothing but great things about it I have
yet to see it because you know I only
got so much [ __ ] time now with the
little kiddo running around who just it
just keeps getting better every day just
keeps getting better every day I don't
know what the [ __ ] people complain about
about having a kid it's [ __ ] awesome
oh my god you're good to go boys as
opposed to what sitting alone in your
apartment it's all the free time in the
[ __ ] world slowly drinking yourself
to death because I'll tell you better
both like in this side a little better
that's saying every once in a while
every once in a while they don't have
visit my old friends that my [ __ ]
83-76 there's level bar that I have I
always throw I always give a shout-out
to the 83-76 because ever he talks about
the 96 bowls he talks about the 27
Yankees what about the 1983 Philadelphia
76ers huh I would love to throw the 86
Celtics in there but the [ __ ] Lakers
choked against the Houston Rockets so I
mean sort of a you know when in the 80s
it didn't mean you didn't really feel
like you want a championship unless you
beat the Celtics of the Lakers that's
basically it that's that's my you know
no disrespect to Ralph [ __ ] Sampson
no [ __ ]
Keem elijah one you see on that team
yeterday a [ __ ] treat no tree Rollins
was Atlanta
I don't remember they had very similar
uniforms in my memory bank in fact I
think they had the exact same colors
just Houston Rockets was less busy' more
traditional like the Detroit Red Wings
jerseys simple red and white toronto
blue and white sit it's over these are
our colors [ __ ] you
somebody please explain to me how the
Tampa Bay [ __ ] Lightning Oso can wear
blue and white I don't understand that
you know it's like the Pittsburgh
Penguins when they came back wearing
black and gold it's like what the [ __ ]
Bartnik told me that the original [ __ ]
hockey team in Pittsburgh did wear black
and gold but then yeah but then you fold
it and you left it on the table it's
like when you don't renew your [ __ ]
website somebody else is gonna get it I
don't know what I'm talking about all I
know is I have to plow through this next
[ __ ] half an hour just to see how
you're doing whatever I may be I'm gonna
catch you on the ride home
you know worst case scenario you got one
[ __ ] day left he was a sick day take
a three-day weekend you know you know
was actually thinking now is this is the
time of year where the spring break
I wonder what kids do nowadays there's
got to be a way where they can get out
of the view of the constant surveillance
of your parents now you know what I mean
Jesus Christ by the time my daughter
gets to that [ __ ] age I'll probably
be able to have a drone like hovering
over her for her the entire [ __ ]
existence I'll just shout down from the
sky you know honey don't go to that
party just freaking around she'd be
looking up like dad oh so sick of my dad
hovering over me in a huh and a [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] it's called that will
literally be helicopter parenting those
[ __ ] drones I went to something
recently I guess the gift bag was a
drone it's like why would you give
people of six it's not intrusive enough
all this [ __ ] technology that all
these [ __ ] weirdos you know what I
mean
I want to know the first time a drone is
gonna seriously give somebody brain
damage because the operator was trying
to jerk off while they were trying to
operate it is they're hovering over
somebody's [ __ ] house you know trying
to come down near the bathroom there's
already perverts doing them perverts
fascinate me but they fascinate basick
why can't just walk up and say hello
they can't do it but then they have
these needs right so then they got a
peak around the corner you know speaking
of peaking peaking blindness one of my
favorite [ __ ] shows that's come out
over the last five years I was on a an
airplane flying back from Austin from
the South by Southwest festival which I
can't tell you another time when you
would not want to be in Austin you know
I mean it's great for films and that
type of [ __ ] but it's just like I don't
know man I don't know what happened to
that city I've been going there for the
last 20 years it just gets more and more
crowded it's like a bunch of sweaty
hippies with l8 level traffic that's
what South by Southwest is and I don't
know what it is every white person in
Austin during that week they all look
like they play hacky sack you know I
don't know if there's just something
about the the disheveled on purpose
college aged white kid that I know I
even when I went to college I wasn't
like that
you know [ __ ] combed my hair when I
still had hair right I didn't try to
[ __ ] look like I lived out on the
street it was like a big guy thing back
then to try to look all [ __ ]
disheveled like I could barely take care
of myself but look at my college ID look
at my crazy picture you did all of this
on this whole [ __ ] thing is on
purpose the end of the [ __ ] day if
your backs against the wall you can call
your mom and dad all right so [ __ ]
comb your hair and put on a clean shirt
all right you [ __ ] I'm sorry why did I
say all of that anyways I this was my
day
I actually was flying out there
that day to do the all things comedy
podcast and then fly right back so I I'm
like this is great I've always wanted go
to the airport and just have like
nothing and just walk in you know like
Leonardo DiCaprio and catch me if you
can maybe just come [ __ ] walking in
wearing this little [ __ ] I know how
to fly plane outfit that's what the [ __ ]
I wanted to do - that outfit so I put on
sweatpants you know and I would have a
[ __ ] t-shirt jacket and I had my
change of clothes and toiletries in this
backpack and that was [ __ ] it all
right went in there like a goddamn
drifter and I get all the way to the
airport and I realized I forgot my
[ __ ] wallet right so I can't get on
the [ __ ] plane because I don't have
any form of identification I don't have
my college ID man from back in the day
and what did I have I ended up having to
go I didn't know what to do I was like
I'm gonna miss this [ __ ] part and I'm
actually thinking now that my dad she
did grow my hair out a little bit in
college but I still dress respectfully
maybe I was a hybrid I can't [ __ ]
remember was so [ __ ] long ago anyways
so I [ __ ] get to the airport I don't
have my goddamn ID and I don't know what
the [ __ ] to do and I have to make this
this podcast because there's advertisers
and all that type of [ __ ] you can't say
this is the lineup this is the projected
amount of people that are gonna listen
it's a business and then not show up and
take their [ __ ] money
so I didn't know what to do so I ended
up for the first time ever I flew
private and blew a [ __ ] ton of cash
so I'm gonna be playing a bunch of
casinos coming up to make up for the
money that I that I spent on that I flew
out of Van Nuys like a [ __ ] rock star
lit up my card literally glowing in my
pocket I had to [ __ ] drive home get
my wallet fly out you know drive out
there and then sit there and then talk
to these [ __ ] savages just being like
oh you need a plane right now I am
really that'll be a million bucks and
I'm like [ __ ] you man I'm cold somebody
else
and they're like it'll be a half a
million I might [ __ ] you okay and all
you do is you just keep calling people
and after a while you just start saying
numbers and I got it I got it way the
[ __ ] down for whatever they first quoted
me I have that got it down to half that
but still cost a [ __ ] zillion bucks
so I get on the plane talking to the
pilot still like right [ __ ] there it
was a smaller plane like when I went to
take a piss I'm like do you guys have a
bathroom here they're like yeah they do
when they had to move the snacks and
then they closed that little door and
I'm taking a piss right on the other
side of the [ __ ] door and like you
can't stand up in the plane so I am
stand up but I'm acting like I have
osteoporosis and I'm trying to take a
[ __ ] piss and this is an angle you
have to be yet so you don't piss on your
own [ __ ] sweat pants but eventually
the velocity of the urine coming out of
your dick is gonna slow down and it's
gonna come towards your clothes so then
you got to make a decision what am I
gonna do this
how far down am I gonna pull my pants
what the [ __ ] going like that weird
kid remember that weird kid when you
were in elementary school you went in to
take a piss and the kid had his pants
all the way down around his ankles it's
like why didn't you just [ __ ] unzip
your fly you know what's going on here
so and then the old time I'm just
thinking like how is this better did fly
in on a commercial airline I don't get
it you know if you fly in business at
first if you bump yourself up that I am
one and done on that [ __ ] I just think
it's the it's a colossal [ __ ] waste
of money and I have the glowing [ __ ]
credit card right now to prove it and
there's just no money in it the [ __ ]
people who rent the planes are barely
making any money the pilots don't make
any money all the pilots won't
eventually fly for commercial a
commercial airline right I mean they're
still flying commercial private but they
want to fly for like you know one of the
major airlines is what I'm trying to say
so one of the pilots came back and he's
talking to me because you know we got
some beers here and I'm like I'm on the
wagon but I'm like what the [ __ ] I spent
all this money I got to have a beer so I
drank a Coors Light like the white-trash
[ __ ] that I am and
he's sitting there talking to me and I'm
all fascinated with all the aviation
aspects of it and I'm sitting there
looking at the guy and he had a tear in
his slacks right at his knee like there
was a like a like a vertical slice like
he was in a knife fight and just
somebody sliced it a little bit and I
was just going like there's no [ __ ]
money in this what this guy is doing
right now defying the law of gravity
getting me from Los Angeles to Austin he
doesn't get lost he knows where to go he
knows what altitude to fly at we had a
nice [ __ ] landing I mean my life is
literally in this guy's hand and they
don't pay this guy enough money that he
can fly this [ __ ] jet without a pair
of pants that have [ __ ] ripped you
know maybe that's why all those kids
[ __ ] annoyed me you know what is I
didn't fit you know when I was in Austin
because I'm seeing a guy who actually
really is struggling flying a [ __ ]
jet and he has [ __ ] a ripped slacks
who knows maybe he just had a rough
night he had a rough one
maybe he just passed out I don't [ __ ]
know anyways I remember when I was in
college and yeah like I I was never that
[ __ ] rebel guy I'm ever walking by
this chick one time and I just had like
mainstream clothes on
I had like a polo shirt and regular [ __ ]
I never I walked by and she just goes
ooh hot labels
[Music]
be like you [ __ ] goth [ __ ] you look
like every other [ __ ] Gothic on here
do you guys all I don't know what
[ __ ] every blacks everything painted
black store you [ __ ] walk in you all
have the same [ __ ] makeup you all
have the same [ __ ] lipstick that's
just you know because there's no goth
foodcourt you feel like you're out of
you're out of the reach of the
corporations I never forget that
ooh hot labels and I kind of liked your
too cuz a lot of those goth chicks were
cute you know if you could get past the
[ __ ] you know nowadays I would
actually I would totally steer clear
them knowing what I know it's like out
God
let me I would have one question do you
or do you not hate your parents you do
and see you I'm not [ __ ] going
through that [ __ ] those [ __ ] long
talks about everything that they did to
you you know hey you know what my
parents did [ __ ] too you know and I'm a
parent now and I'm gonna do [ __ ] you
know that doesn't mean you got to
[ __ ] walk around dressed like you're
in a wake okay I mean why you dressed
like that cuz you got bullied now look
at you now you're just bringing this
[ __ ] onto yourself what are you waiting
for bullies to become enlightened and be
like oh I guess people have the right to
be different it's not gonna happen so at
the very least if you're gonna walk
around like that it least at some point
take the makeup off go into a dojo and
learn some [ __ ] MMA [ __ ] so you can
protect yourself so I guess in the end
of the day I'm not really attacking goth
people I'm really saying how much [ __ ]
her she still judged me right ooh hot
labels I've said one of those things
where you walk and you kind of stop for
half a second and then you is is it
worth it it's not worth it I just kept
going
I forget what her [ __ ] name was it
was either Natasha a Brooke which was
always a [ __ ] hot girl name when I
was growing up never really saw a Brooke
that wasn't good looking
Natasha's were good-looking Debbie's
Debbie's will fund Debbie's were fun
girls weird like different you give a
[ __ ] person a name you know I mean it
was like Bill you know just blending in
Bill lost in the crowd all mainstream
bill with his corporate clothes just
walking down the street I did have the
red afro for a while when I got into
[ __ ] radio
I [ __ ] grew it out a little bit and I
think I had the beard oh that's when I
got into drums and I was trying to be in
a band and that's what I was trying to
grow my hair out and it just went out
which would have been cool in the 60s or
70s I would look like Bernie from room
222 but by the
ATS it wasn't cool you had to have the
long [ __ ] hand just never worked for
me the comedy gods they just pulled me
in it's like listen bill you look like a
douche no matter what you do okay you're
not a good-looking guy you look like a
[ __ ] freak
okay the only hope for you is to stand
on stage and make fun of yourself and
make a little bit of money money - I
don't you cash in on your orange afro
you know I think that that's what was
going on eventually I that's what I did
that is exactly what I did and then when
I was making enough money in the
business the comedy God said okay you
don't need your orange afro anymore and
they took it from me I'm talking about
oh I know what I wanted to bring up two
weeks in a row I'm gonna give you a
great movie I told you I saw Jordan
peels get out which is so [ __ ] such a
no great movie and so you know different
from everything else that's out there
I'm actually going to enjoy watching
Hollywood now try to rip that movie off
it's like get out meets people who don't
know how to make it get out I think
they're gonna do the Latino version
however you say get out in a Latino you
know so I know vamanos I don't what the
[ __ ] you say I was starting to remember
Sesame Street when we had enter and exit
a bientot oh that was close I don't
[ __ ] room I don't know you know
whatever it's some [ __ ] white guy
we'll get a rosetta stone and he'll
figure out how to say it try to rip off
that movie that was a great movie and
this week I was on the plane ride back
from Austin wait a minute typing in my
password and I saw the guy from peaky
blinders
Killian Murphy don't know nothing about
no robbery I'll [ __ ] you with the
[ __ ] password hang on there we go
it's called I don't I hope I say this
right it's anthropoid a
thr Opio ID and it's based on they say
the extraordinary true story of
operation anthropoid the world war ii
mission to attempt to assassinate SS
general reinhard heydrich and what i
love is it's a story i never heard you
know granted I don't [ __ ] read and it
takes place in Czechoslovakia in Prague
and I had no idea
I knew that Germany you know they lost I
guess
Austria in World War one and then you
know a star came back and he's just like
once if he should have that and they
just took [ __ ] Austria and nobody in
Europe did anything and everything's
just like well maybe that's maybe
they'll just be happy with that and we
won't get involved in this [ __ ] world
war thing again and then I thought he
went immediately to Poland but evidently
old [ __ ] evil Charlie Chaplin himself
went to Czechoslovakia I had no idea and
made me want to read up on the subject
and it's a [ __ ] amazing amazing movie
and it's one of those movies where what
they're talking about the behavior was
so heroic as you're watching it you're
actually sort of squirming going like
how would I react what I would hope that
I would be one of these you know the
good guys here as opposed to the person
just trying to blend in well they're not
coming after me and I just sort of did
whatever the [ __ ] they see and I'll
choose like self-preservation which I
got to be honest with you like I would
never fault a parent for doing that cuz
once you got your kid like you're just
like so focused on your [ __ ] kid you
just like [ __ ] all adults you know not
[ __ ] all adults it's just like well I'm
not creating a situation like a kid you
know but you'd like to think like you
know what [ __ ] that I'm gonna teach my
kid how to shoot a [ __ ] Uzi and let's
go Nazi honey you know you'd like to
think that you would that person as
opposed to sitting there quietly eating
your soggy corn flakes
you know this is the thing about being a
coward is if nobody else knows you'll
forgive yourself
you know it's other people knowing and
just staring at your shoes for the then
you know waiting for the people that
know what a coward you were during that
time eventually die or you die or
whatever but it's a [ __ ] unbelievable
[ __ ] movie absolutely loved it and
directed by Sean Ellis I like this I
like giving shoutouts cuz not a lot of
people go to movies anymore shoutouts
all these [ __ ] talented people here
and it stars Jamie Dornan Killian Murphy
I hope I said that right it's spelled CI
L Li a and come on you gotta have a
couple of broads in here with some lovin
just right I'm never gonna say this sera
amorous Irish trova on a fried joke joke
for Jesus Christ is like trying to name
a [ __ ] hockey player now hannah FR e
j KO v a with a [ __ ] hatchet mark
right above it I don't know what lose it
was amazing great [ __ ] movie check it
out if you get a chance if you're on
American Airlines it's plane I don't
know if they get extra money if they do
it that way I don't know alright anyways
let's read a little bit of advertising
here for this week what do we got here
oh do me on DS me undie shoot a couple
[ __ ] Nazis but who do me on these me
undies playing when you're wearing
Yahtzee hey [ __ ] Ryan [ __ ] off your
[ __ ] balls will feel real nice shave
your head if you got lice I like me
undies on my taint it makes me have
really good dreams oh yeah unlike the
generic ones when you're wearing Hanes
right hot labels alright me undies
oh man that one's stuck with you they're
amazing the things that stick with you
that was almost 30 [ __ ] years ago and
I still remember it like it was
yesterday
ooh hot labels you know if I had a time
machine like I wouldn't go back and try
and stop Hitler I'd go back to that
moment my
life so I could turn around and be like
and that'll be that'll be it that would
be it I get right back in and I would
leave anyways immunities elevate your
underwear game your underwear game yo to
the next level with me I'm beyond me
you've perfected your wardrobe hey but
what about the stuff not everybody gets
to see man if you've been settling for
store-bought underwear five packs have
you been settling to go into the [ __ ]
mall and buying a pack of five pairs of
underwear that some [ __ ] kid had to
sew together in El Salvador if you're
sick of going through that difficult
thing I have something that will change
your life for the better and that is
[ __ ] me on DS what's the first thing
you put on the last thing you take off
huh what is it your underwear right
unless you leave your hat on you [ __ ]
weirdo
it's your underwear make your most
important piece of clothing the best it
can be with me undies well the last time
you were completely naked and you just
had on a hat you know if there's anybody
in the room they're [ __ ] laughing
right you cannot be completely naked and
just have on a hat and not do a dance
it's impossible especially if your guy
then you got your junks [ __ ] shakin
around it's tremendous it's a great show
actually what is me undies oh just
seriously soft feel good undies
delivered right to your door
me undies are designed in Los Angeles or
Louisiana they don't really say la and
made from sustainable source micro
motile modal a fabric three times softer
than cotton be undies softer than soft
luxury undies come in an ever-changing
selection of classic colors what is
classic colors this probably your basic
you know crayon set when you're a little
kid what's your favorite color
whoa all right blue red white black
brown yellow green that's it that's it
like the original members of Guns
N'Roses then all of a sudden you get
burnt sienna
you know when Matt Sorum comes in and
you get a little [ __ ] I don't know
some other [ __ ] cutoff white when you
get was that guy dizzy [ __ ] something
rather anyways bolt shapes at French for
its pattern so you can tailor your
undies to your own personal style and
guess what guess what you can
save time and money each month with a
monthly subscription how much do you
[ __ ] your pants that you need underwear
every month and if you're not ready for
a subscription that's okay you can still
save that's because my undies is
offering you 20% off the first pair just
use our special URL me undies dot-com /
/ and get 20% off your first pair so go
ahead revamp your underwear drawer you
deserve it
it'll put you in a good mood man new
underwear new socks you know that's like
a body off restoration you know you're
not just putting a coat of paint on this
piece of [ __ ] the new pair of slacks
keep going right down heel bowls
once again that's me undies dot-com / /
me undies dot-com / / a better day for
your taint all right frame bridge
everybody do you guys have a bunch of
photos laying around well do you you got
art that's rolled up in your closet just
waiting for you to put it in a nice
frame to hang on the walls but you know
what a [ __ ] deal with that [ __ ] would
it be great if there was just something
you know you called frame bridge calm
you could send them all that [ __ ] then
it would come back to your house Frank
you can put it up on your walls and
pretend you're interesting would that be
great well you can do that with fray
bridge calm do you take a thousand
photos that never get put on a single
frame now you can get those great
memories off your camera on your wall
with frame bridge com why frame bridge
you might ask well prices start at just
39 bucks and are up to 70 s percent less
than traditional framing stores go to
frame bridge calm you choose your frame
from there curated collection upload
your art preview it before you buy can't
upload your art you stupid bastard no
worries you can mail it in for free your
frame piece of art at your home arrives
at your home ready to hang get your
personal experience using frame bridge
calm the sight the ease of order how
your piece turned out and how easy and
affordable it was I know I read that
wrong anyways I love frame bridge
evidently I know you will - it's so easy
to use I just delivered that like walkin
it's so easy to use so much so much more
affordable than traditional frame stores
right now frame
komm has a special offer just for my
listeners wherever else they advertise
with 50% off your first order and free
shipping when you use my code burg so
get started get started framing your art
or picture go to frame bridge comm find
your favorite frame from the curated
collection upload your art or mail
upload your art or mail it in for free
preview your art and your custom frame
enter my code birth check out to get 15%
off and free shipping don't wait this
offer expires this week so go to frame
bridge com use my code Burpee you are
are to save do you like to booze huh do
you like to get [ __ ] up but you don't
want to get pulled over for drinking and
driving wouldn't be great if there was a
service that was like a taxi service but
it wasn't it was just some person in a
car
well I introduced you to lift ly ft
because you can never spell it the
correct way in the modern era in the
modern era right it's gotta be it's
gotta be funky get people over that's
not LIF T man that's for squares
this is ly ft like why would you drive
when you're drink in you know you know
about lift right right
it's the app that gets you a ride in
minutes on-demand 24/7 for less than the
cost of a cab please include the
following points by the way that [ __ ]
commercial I think it's for lyft that
they do on TV where the people are
robbing the bank and they're freaking
out then there's that one kid just
sitting there going like oh the guy's
name Tim that's a great name he's
totally [ __ ] relaxed don't that
[ __ ] actor and that is should
immediately be put in movies that's my
own personal opinion I thought it was
very unique that's all I'm saying it's a
great commercial veteran all the way
around
- thumbs up anyways please include the
following points during your read ok if
you tried lifts you know what I mean
with lifts you just download the app
request a driver and they show up in 3
and a half minutes on average that's
really fast everybody knows how this
[ __ ] works every lyft driver is fully
vetted through that ten point safety
standard one have you ever [ __ ] a kid
okay good we moved to the second round -
have you ever had a drone crash into
your neighbor because you were jerking
off watching them take a shower no okay
three now have you ever been sympathetic
to the Communist Party whatever the [ __ ]
they say after that it kind of goes off
the rails you know once you haven't
[ __ ] a kid you know you haven't killed
anybody then it's kind of like yeah you
know you like the boosts I know how much
do you like the boosts 10-point standard
including criminal and DMV background
checks you know you'll get around
quickly and safety lyft drivers are
rated after every ride it's only the
best stick around this is like Bill
Belichick do your [ __ ] job you don't
have to worry about getting into a
filthy car with some creepy dude with
lifts you can tip in the app which
obviously leads to happier drivers so
right now lyft is offering our listeners
a special deal they get three free
[ __ ] rides dude up to ten dollars
each that's up to a $30 value if you
can't do basic math when you enter the
promo code bill Barbie I ll be URR all
in capital letters to make me feel
important just download the free lyft
app today and enter the promo code bill
burr no space all capitals you will
respect me in the payments section
you'll start with three free rides up to
ten dollars each that's up to a $30
value if you haven't if you do not have
the ability to do basic math 10 times 3
is 30
that's promo code bill bird no spaces
all capital letters enter promo code
bill burr no space all capital letters
ok you put my name's and you put my name
and [ __ ] lights on that goddamn
website all right
what are you up to well there's my
half-hour just like that just like that
Oh wouldn't it be nice if you would shut
up I'm gone in a minute what do I have
on the thing oh I have a benefit benefit
on March 25th a time for EMS and it's
here in LA I for some reason don't have
the information in front of me I don't
[ __ ] along co-hosting it with Craig
Gass
it's rock against ms I believe there's
gonna be a bunch of musicians there
Steven Adler again [ __ ] Gilby claw
Rudy Sarzo Michael Devon all of these
[ __ ] rock stars are gonna be there
we're gonna raise a bunch of money to
help try and find a cure for this bad
horrific disease as opposed to what bill
a wonderful disease what about the
disease of laughter I don't think we
ever want to cure that do we
sorry I'm gonna be in San Jose this week
everybody Monday Tuesday Wednesday I'm
doing two shows a night I got my new
[ __ ] going on I was supposed to do the
goddamn Comedy Jam but my [ __ ] show
is messed up and I've been driving my
old truck too that's three on the tree
and that's the shoulder that's [ __ ] up
but actually was bothering me just to
shift on the column that's how [ __ ]
old I am like some day I might have to
sell that truck because it hurts my
shoulder so just shift it only has three
gears I know it's [ __ ] pathetic I've
been falling off on the Bruins and the
Celtics I know the Bruins scored a bunch
of goals I know we beat the Bulls the
other day but then the the Bruins scored
like six goals 4 goals in the third
period I watched the first period of
both the Vancouver and the Calgary game
and that was always my fantasy when I
was young as a fan when I went on the
road you know I was just like I would
love to do that [ __ ] Western Canada
road trip you know back then it was
Calgary Edmonton Vancouver and maybe
played Winnipeg too and then the last
then they went down and they played the
LA Kings and LA Kings were just sitting
way out in the West with nobody nearer
like the closest [ __ ] team I think
was Vancouver and then the next closest
would probably would have been the st.
Louis Blues maybe Chicago Blackhawks I
would guess st. Louis they were just
there was no [ __ ] team west of st.
Louis
other than the LA Kings so no wonder
they had such a higher time took him so
long to win a [ __ ]
along they had to fly Vancouver's never
[ __ ] one one Calgary one once right
and 89 they beat [ __ ] Patrick War and
the montreal canadiens I want to say Pat
Burns was coaching that team I can't
remember but Edmonton Edmonton [ __ ]
lit it up so anyways let me see if they
beat Calgary last night Boston where we
go Bruins here we go Boston Bruins
they're flying around the ice ice up
posture knocks 29th goal he's really
feeling filling the Tyler Seguin void
wouldn't you say you know since Tyler
Seguin left that Marshawn became a
legitimate superstar and now posture
knock is on his way so I guess we're
doing all right
you know we survived it and I actually
think Tyler Seguin oh they're showing us
congratulating ourselves I think we want
Bruins extinguished the flames you get
it you get it it's like they're on fire
David back has returned from a collision
into the boards yeah that was scary that
look like me and pick up hockey for
fucksakes where did this story go game
we scored the game winner is the Bruins
down the flames five to two in Calgary
on Wednesday night we scored six goals
in Vancouver 5 X 11 goals in two [ __ ]
games you know all my [ __ ] [ __ ]
moaning and complaining Marcia and
humbled by emerging status as a lead
scorer yeah that's absolutely right what
about pastina Marshawn had a hat-trick
in Vancouver and I [ __ ] missed it
dude all of a sudden were scoring goals
and I was sitting there wine and saying
do not get rid of close Julian and it's
been it's totally worked out it's worked
out for us has worked out for him it's
worked out for the Canadians so it's all
good and we're flying around the ice
with the new coach Cassidy that's
[ __ ] great
it's [ __ ] great I love it I love it's
good to see dougie Hamilton to seem to
be doing all right out there and Kent
and Calgary I know I never have a
[ __ ] problem with X Bruins even if
they decided to try to take more money I
don't give a [ __ ] it's your career have
a good time good to see you still in the
league you know I know you're out there
in the
the Saddledome that doesn't get a lot of
love down here in the lower 48 and say
say in Alaska anyways that's the podcast
I got to get on with my [ __ ] day here
oh my god my wife said the [ __ ]
greatest thing to me ever to [ __ ]
motivate me to workout I was sitting
there looking in the mirror in the
bathroom I just fat shamed myself every
[ __ ] night that's how I stay in shape
right and I just you know I went off the
rails and I ate it's taken shake twice I
hated McDonald's twice and had Burger
King this month has been like fast food
when I've been on the road I don't
what's been going on with me right so I
was looking at the results of that diet
and I was just look in the mirror and I
called myself a tub of [ __ ] which I've
never said in my life I was just like
you [ __ ] soft mushy tub of [ __ ]
and then neo was in the other room going
like what's going on with you like I
don't know look at me I'm [ __ ] I'm a
mess she goes you know looked at bad I
go yeah I do look at me I got a [ __ ]
dad bod now and she goes no you don't I
got Nick you're not helping me
you know I need honesty here and then
she just goes alright you're not is tone
as you once were and I just went she
goes I'm sorry you said that I said no
you're doing me a favor so that's it now
I've been on it I've been on it like the
Joe Rogan company I've been [ __ ] on
it alright
oatmeal [ __ ] poached egg in the
morning by the way when you make your
poached eggs if you want to have them
like they do in the restaurant you know
it's it's spooning with itself this is
such a simple trick I didn't even know
it for all these years just swirl the
water I know I've said this before but
maybe you missed the podcast just swirl
the water get a little whirlpool going
okay and then you crack the egg you drop
it right down the center and it's like a
figure skater you know when they do the
[ __ ] spinning around it just it
brings its arms in and then you go you
take it out with a slotted spoon you put
it on a [ __ ] English muffin unless
you like me if you're a tub of [ __ ] and
you're trying to lose weight there's no
English muffin it's just sitting there
naked and afraid that is the dumbest
[ __ ]
you know there's no prize these people
go out there and get like [ __ ] Lyme
disease got ants crawling around their
balls and up into their [ __ ] private
parts I mean I just don't understand why
you would do that
caveman we're not naked they were
definitely afraid but they [ __ ]
killed something and they covered up
their junk I actually saw this guy naked
in a [ __ ] tree with a hatchet this is
just a commercial because I refuse to
watch that I don't watch that show you
know black people won't watch [ __ ] that
because it's a bad representation of
themselves that's what that show is for
white people there's very few shows out
there that bring white people down you
know because white people are running
[ __ ] so we always make ourselves the
[ __ ] heroes make it in afraid that's
not a good show for white people that is
every stereotype of a [ __ ] white
person just like you know I think my
life is just too [ __ ] easy I got to
make it difficult what do I just took
all my clothes off went to the [ __ ]
jungle Soph I could survive naked and
afraid so this [ __ ] guy and just in
the commercial floor he's up in a tree
and he's [ __ ] hacking at this branch
in this tree he's sitting in and then
the whole [ __ ] branch collapses and
it's just like that reminds me of some
[ __ ] from like Bugs Bunny where the
somebody be sitting on a branch in this
sawn-off and it's sitting on the wrong
side of it then they fall off or the
whole tree falls down I literally
watched this guy do it live-action a
real person did that to himself he
wasn't but he was hacking on the right
side but still I don't know what
happened the whole thing [ __ ] Falls
and now he's falling in to like a bunch
of like branches sticking out like with
just completely naked you know I never
cut my balls my entire life I never got
a scratch on my balls nothing cuz they
were covered up they had on a pair of
pants climbs a [ __ ] tree naked
anyways I don't know why I'm talking
about this I don't know why I have this
level of passion for a [ __ ] show I
don't I don't even watch that's the yeah
I checked in on you okay you guys you
guys have you guys have yourself a great
[ __ ] weekend all right you're [ __ ]
and I will I'll talk to you on Monday I
right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves and
God bless the United States of America
hey what's going on it still fur it is
the Monday morning podcast for Monday
March 16 2009 um I don't know what this
is the year of anybody Asian listening
or is it the year of is it the year of
the monkey
um I am in San Francisco right now and
uh I can't believe it it's drizzling out
and it's cold and it's miserable it's
just I just blew my mind because every
time I come to San Francisco the weather
is just it's just you know it just puts
a smile on your face you know it's just
one of those you know wait I I don't
know when the [ __ ] they ever film that
rice-a-roni commercial but it must have
been like the one sunny day in the last
ten [ __ ] years out here because this
is a 12-time I've come to this city I
just pulled that number out of the air
but whatever the weather sucked every
time and it's like practically
impossible um and not to mention I had a
touch of a cold I usually get sick when
I come here I was actually a little bit
sick before I got here how did you get
sick bill well I'll tell you I went to
Joshua Tree National Park and evidently
I didn't dress properly as I hiked my
way out to somebody's gold mine
literally Joshua Tree definitely
definitely a good time although I made a
real I made a big-time fool of myself I
showed up and I asked the Ranger I swear
to God he was a ranger but he's working
the gift shop so I figured he sucks at
being a ranger you know enemy probably
accidentally started a fire rather than
put in one out in the park so I asked
the Ranger I you know it's called Joshua
Tree so in my mind you know there's this
big beautiful park and this is one
[ __ ] Joshua Tree and that's what
everybody comes up to and you know like
that
what's that wall at all those Jewish
people go up and pray to I thought it
was something like that some sort of
Mecca right so I say yeah your guy gives
me the map of the whole the whole park
it's like
I'm actually getting embarrassed telling
the story I actually said so where
exactly is the Joshua tree is it like
isn't like one tree is it like a group
of like five trees and the guys looking
at me and just the way he looked at me I
just realized I just said probably the
dumbest [ __ ] thing I could possibly
say within the park and evidently this
is what I learned and in defense of
myself I am from the East Coast every
contently a Joshua tree is just the type
of tree and I probably driven by like
200 of them on the way up to [ __ ]
talking to this Ranger there was
probably three of them in the parking
lot basically there for you people on
the East Coast
whoever if you ever go out there there
is no Joshua Tree it's just a type of
tree and if you go to Joshua Tree and
you say so where is the Joshua Tree that
would like be that'd be like going to
New Jersey and going where is the pine
tree like the V pine tree that you know
this special one and you know it just
yeah I don't know I you know I just got
the directions I just found out how to
[ __ ] get there I had no information
about it but you know in defense of me
they should name the park Joshua trees
plural not Joshua Tree it confuses
people then they ask silly questions and
then they feel stupid and then they tell
it that we tell the story in the podcast
may get slightly embarrassed um so
anyways that was my week oh you know I
went to a San Jose Sharks game on
Saturday night on my way up here to do
my one my two shows here up in San
Francisco so the Sharks beat the Kings
in a shootout and at the game I saw a
fifty to fifty I played about 55 58 year
old guy punch of 27 year old kid right
in the face and it was [ __ ] hilarious
it was his kid he had on this Detroit
Redwings Jersey aids hat on backwards
you know and right out of the gate he's
just standing up screaming [ __ ] and he
was cheering on the shark so evidence I
don't know what happened
I think if he kept standing up anyways
this this chick who is also like 55:58
she's got this awful fur coat on you
know in San Jose so you know she thinks
she's somebody I'm sure that's a fancy
thing to do in San Jose California but a
[ __ ] ghost town that was by the way
is that nobody on the streets right so
uh yes speaking of which like I actually
was going cheap where the [ __ ] I was
going to stay and I actually decided to
stay at this Ramada you know thinking
that it was you know like all right it's
like 89 bucks for the night [ __ ] it I'll
stay here and I pull in and it's one of
those deals where the hotel rooms open
up out to the parking lot and if you're
a fan of my podcast you know I feel
about those I do not stay I don't stay
in motels okay even if you call it a
hotel if it [ __ ] opens up if your
room opens up out into the parking lot
that's a [ __ ] motel can somebody tell
me what what is the definition of a
motel versa Hotel because if my world if
your door opens up to the parking lot
that is a motel slash this serial killer
buffet where they can just walk down and
be like I'm going to kill this guy I'm
going to kill this guy and I'm [ __ ]
with that guy so I never even checked in
nor did I cancel my reservation so I
wonder I wonder if I'll have to pay for
that alright I ended up just calling the
marryin around the corner not even
worried about whether they had a [ __ ]
room available because I saw that there
was only six people on the street four
of which were [ __ ] crackheads um yeah
so anyway so I go to this [ __ ] game
get back on track here yeah so this
woman is this fur coat all of a sudden
she gets into it with this guy wearing
this this Red Wings jersey and you know
she's giving him [ __ ] he's giving it
right back to her which of course I'm
loving you know to me it usually guys
back down to women once they start
screaming in public and he didn't he
just kept giving a [ __ ] right back and I
don't know what she said but she goes
yeah you just try me or something like
that which was really [ __ ] annoying
you know I have a woman act like they're
going to get physical
with a man like they going to knock them
out it's like we shut up you know I
can't hit you I mean I could but I'm
instantly going to go to [ __ ] jail
and then I'm going to get raped you know
so stop acting like you're [ __ ] tough
the law is on your side alright so she's
doing all that [ __ ] and he's giving her
[ __ ] right back and then it sort of died
down and I started watching the game
again and next thing you know there's
just this commotion and I look over my
left again now the kid in the Red Wings
jersey is covered in beer and he's John
at the the lady with the fur coat and
obviously she dumped it over his head
you know I mean of course I went to if
it was illegal to kick the [ __ ] out of
me so she dumps it over a head and he
doesn't blast her in the face just
adding to her kunti level that she's
going to be the following day the fact
that she got away with that and didn't
get dropped I'm not advocating I don't
think you should hit a woman but I don't
feel that women should take advantage of
the fact that a man can't hit them by
just doing over-the-top kunti things
like just dumping a beer on somebody you
know what I mean so anyway so she dumps
a beer on the guy which I got him it is
also hilarious on another level so I
didn't hear the exchange I guess I don't
know what happened all of a sudden this
[ __ ] old guy comes into the picture
he's got his faces all twisted up with
angry anger and he just says to the kid
he goes who you calling a [ __ ] he must
have called the chicken of fur-coat a
[ __ ] and the kid didn't say anything
and I swear to god this [ __ ] 55 year
old dude it was the slowest punch I've
ever seen in my life he literally lifted
his hand up like a rock em sock em robot
and just threw this straight not even to
see I don't know what the [ __ ] it was it
was like Rock'em Sock'em he just he sort
of bought them right rather than those
and then the kid just immediately called
for security and I was just like wow
that's really a tough situation there
like he just dealt with to the toughest
physical confrontation a woman dumps a
beer will be ahead you want to punch her
in the face but you can't but then you
allowed her to dump it over your head so
he deals with that then he has an old
guide punch him in the face it's like
another man just punched
faith you want to drill them back but
you can't because he's an old guy but
then you will out an old guy to punch
you in the face so at this point this
guy socially has been raped right so I'm
thinking when security comes down like
all right this guy got punched in the
face and a beer over his head he might
actually you know he should get out of
this even though he's younger than the
two of them you're gonna be sympathetic
with the old people but he immediately
screws up cuz the security gets there he
just starts cursing his brains out god I
didn't do [ __ ] I was just [ __ ]
watching the [ __ ] kick they just
snatched him they actually snatched all
three of them and 20 minutes later
somehow the kid with the Red Wings
Jersey came back and the two old people
didn't and I was thinking how the [ __ ]
did he pull that off and the only way I
can think of it is if the old guy
admitted to punching him in the face
which is probably what someone would do
if they weren't a lawyer he probably
said well this guy punched me in the
face and then he probably said I did it
because you called my wife a [ __ ] and
then it became do you want to press
charges and then the old guy gets scared
and grabs his Walker and he leaves and
then the [ __ ] Detroit Redwings kid
came back that was my experience was
that just a long boring story that went
nowhere I kind of lost interest towards
the end of that my mouth started getting
dry anyway this is the mud the Monday
morning podcast and if you're new to my
podcast I do one of these every single
week and I think it's becoming really
relevant during these tough economic
times you know to just give away
something free like this I'm only
mentioning that is free because somebody
told me that they find it annoying when
people say it's a free podcast you know
it's like really well it is a free
podcast you [ __ ] douche bag and
despite the fact that it's free people
still [ __ ] at me every week you know so
yeah I am going to throw it in your face
that I'm doing this for free what do you
think about that let it guilt you just
like your grandmother you know I saw one
of the greatest movie trailers I've ever
seen in my life do you guys you guys
fans of the movie The Dirty Dozen well
what is wrong with you you should be go
go on YouTube
pods you don't need to listen to me
right now this is all you need to do if
you want to be entertained for free just
go on youtube and type in the Dirty
Dozen and watch watch the movie trailer
of it and they have one of the greatest
lines I think that has ever been written
and they're describing basically the
premise of the movie is these 12 guys
who are basically either on death row or
facing really long prison sentences and
if they agree to go on this suicide
mission to kill a bunch of Nazi officers
if they survive they get to go free and
that's the movie so they're basically
describing all the characters and one of
the characters they described as an
Indian with war paint smeared on his
soul I can't do it justice I cannot do
it justice the guy's doing it in that
movie voice and he's not doing it with a
hint of how [ __ ] hilarious it is
because it wasn't hilarious back then an
Indian with warpage smeared on his soul
it's just it's [ __ ] awesome I want
that as my ringtone
anyway so let's get on with the podcast
yeah like we new to my podcast people
send me questions I answer might answer
the questions the best I can
people send me their list of underrated
things they find underrated or overrated
and movie reviews and the latest the
latest is people are telling me stories
of a revenge all right so here's one and
they're really long because people
really are writing me like Stephen King
length stories of revenge now personally
what I've been saying throughout this is
I don't do revenge I I enjoy hearing the
stories but I don't do it because I just
my karma is too [ __ ] strong I don't
know man like there's something about
revenge
unless it's face-to-face you know you
just sort of fight somebody you know
that seems like an honorable kind of
revenge but when you sort of you start
the second year like looking at another
human being and they don't know you're
looking at them and you're trying to
playing some diabolical [ __ ] I don't
know about you guys but there's
something inside of me I can't [ __ ]
do it because I just I never feel more
evil I mean I'm not gonna lie to you
I've sat around and thought about it but
to actually carry it out now who knows
maybe it's exciting I never feel more
alive than when I'm plotting the death
of my next door neighbour all right
there we go
uh you know that sound bite might come
back to haunt me in the future when I
pull my Robert Blake in my 60s take that
one on the context all right it's
against the podcast one I would try to
skip through most of this and just get
to the gist of it uh
pill I was going to college in
Washington State but I was skipping all
of my classes and getting horrible
grades the school I was going to was
University of Puget Sound easily the
worst place I've ever [ __ ] been -
yeah - Yetta Yetta
so anyways there was this kid who was a
friend of mine and at the beginning of
the summer he was in front of his at the
beginning of the semester but I slowly
started to realize that he was a piece
of [ __ ] which culminated when he also
having red hair [ __ ] my then
girlfriend when she was drunk that make
sense basically he had this friend of
unis semester he thought he was cool he
gradually realizes he's a piece of [ __ ]
and it culminated when he [ __ ] his
then girlfriend when she was drunk there
we go so anyways uh what he said was
that this was actually one of the better
moments of my time at the college
hearing that they had hooked up and
finding her the next day the next
morning sorry and she literally could
not look me in the eye which in
hindsight I find extremely funny and she
exchanged she in an inn shamed way
explained that she thought the other guy
was me but she was so drunk she didn't
notice needless to say I was not
understanding with her at all and maybe
out of character choice to go back to
not [ __ ] anyone well good for you man
it's a strong choice hey don't be alone
good move but this of course ended my
friendship with that piece-of-shit kid
since he confirmed what I had been
suspecting about him about being a an
[ __ ] so bla bla bla bla bla
so basically the kid stops going to
class he starts drinking every day and
he ends up dropping out so he's cleaning
out basically his room he goes so it's
my last day I'm happy I'm happier than a
crackhead with a hundred dollar bill
packing my [ __ ] up
then the [ __ ] who [ __ ] my
girlfriend somehow found me in the hall
checking myself out of my room and he
comes up to me with this an incredible
shitty [ __ ] eating grin and he says how
much he's going to miss me in that
thickly sarcastic tone and then actually
proceeded to pinch my cheek like your
grandmother used to when you were six
I'm sure you know the feeling of shaking
with rage being unable to do anything
being unable to do anything assaulting a
kid at a liberal arts school with
security guards right in front of me
would get me arrested but of course I
still felt like the world's biggest
gaping [ __ ] for not doing anything at
all something had to be done about this
and here comes the revenge ladies and
gentlemen okay I decided if he said like
that kids from the rent story last week
I decided to [ __ ] with his car now Jesus
Christ dude you know that's that's
really not that's not the man that's not
the that's not the John Wayne move there
you know you should have you could have
always gone back when the security
wasn't there and then just sort of just
[ __ ] smashed him in the face you
would I don't know so anyway he decides
to [ __ ] with his car dude you remind me
of that that that Chicken Fast Times at
Ridgemont High that's what what's what
women do they think they write dick or
prick on the side of your car whatever
what am I going to do I want to stop
judging I'll just read the rest of the
story so he had decided to [ __ ] with
this car he had a nice Jetta and I knew
where he parked it every night so I got
a friend to be my lookout as much as a
scumbag as I am for [ __ ] with someone
else's car alright we ste admitted it
this could not have gone any better
miraculously there was there was this
perfect gap in the security patrols
giving me just enough time
every panel on his car and slash all
four tires until I was back on the
sidewalk with my friend immediately
after finishing security guards showed
up old people started doing their
early-morning walk to cetera and I got
the [ __ ] out of there within an hour I
caught a bus to Seattle and commerce
started working almost immediately only
an hour in front of my friend's
apartment an hour later in front of my
friend's apartment I started feeling
awful I went from feeling totally fine
to having a a hallucinatory fever I lay
in my friend's bed for an entire day
until around 4:00 when apparently that
jackass discovered what I did to his car
and called my phone over and over from a
number from his number then from all my
friends phones etc I don't remember much
of his this conversation but I do know I
was trying to be a tough guy
bla bla bla bla bla so the kid kept
calling for months and months eventually
I stopped answering his calls but he he
kept calling dude you [ __ ] with a
psycho you know when he came up and
pinched your cheek like that and said
how much do you realize how what a
sadistic [ __ ] maniac you were dealing
with it's probably good you didn't
[ __ ] punch him because he probably
would have came at you like Hannibal
Lecter and bit in the chunky a cheek
right out of your face but anyways he
said he even called me on Christmas
almost a month later when he would call
at these times always unavailable uh oh
this is a good party I'd answer and he'd
start making heavy breathing noises
after a while like those telephone
perverts women were afraid of in the
1960s story has a happy ending though at
one of those hipsters bar a sort of
gothic coffee shop actually I managed to
hook up with a girl that was probably
out of my league by playing off his
constant psycho phone calls as though
there were other chicks trying to get
with me I don't know what it felt like
the number one thing with like with
revenge I'm sorry like that was really
choppy but I swear to god the kid wrote
me like a manifesto I was really trying
to I don't have time to edit these
[ __ ] things but uh that seems to be
people's number one way of
taking revenge on somebody you know you
got to get out there and [ __ ] with their
car I guess dad what's makes it then
right revenge has to be sneaky actually
wait a minute we've had two guys [ __ ]
with a car and we had another guy who
took his girlfriend to Disneyland his
ex-girlfriend have cheated on him it did
horrific things to her you know it is
about revenge it has to be sneaky
because even that chick thought she was
going to Disneyland to ride on the
teacups and to get back with this guy
and he was actually taking her down
there to make a porno
do you know something that's that's what
it is about revenge I can't deal with I
can't deal with the dishonesty of it
there's just something that just makes
you feel like he just feel dirty you
know he [ __ ] up somebody's cars you're
doing right in front of him they should
look at him with some maniacal look on
your face I mean that would really you
know wouldn't that get him because then
he'd be like wow this guy knows I'd [ __ ]
him up if he [ __ ] with my car and not
only is he doing it in front of me he
made sure he called out my name so I saw
him doing it you don't I mean
you know that reminds me of what time I
saw this crazy white dude on the subway
and he was rapping some song and that
had the n-word in it and there was like
10 black people on the train okay and
he's dropping the N bomb every five
seconds I like it I'm crazy Edward some
some some I'm crazy and we're doing the
best I can and then he go whew you just
kept doing it over and over freaking out
of his [ __ ] mind but why is hell on
the downtown six back in the day when I
lived on the Upper East Side he kept
saying it over and over again I was like
you know the subway there's like 1015
black dudes on the train
who's the white dude he's dropping
Edward every white person knows if you
[ __ ] do that if it's instantaneous
ass-kicking but I think that that's what
saved him it's because he was so overtly
doing it all the black people looked at
him were like this guy knows we're gonna
kick the [ __ ] out of him yet he's still
doing it so then you just do the quick
math oh he's [ __ ] crazy he's crazy oh
okay I'm gonna fight this guy and he's
going to bite me and I'm gonna get
hepatitis so that's the honey what the
[ __ ] point I'm trying to make there
that's how you get out of I guess you
know got not getting your act because if
you can truly convince people that
you're [ __ ] crazy like people just
say date they don't they don't mess with
you so that's what you should have done
then you wanna key this [ __ ] car in
front of them they just have a maniacal
look at your face and every other
sentence just scream away and they leave
you alone
anyone ever dealt with the phone calls
then again you wouldn't hooked up with
the chick in the coffee shop I don't
let's get to the podcast questions shall
we I get a fine at [ __ ] I get a cold
here okay I'll make an excuse for that
last two minutes doesn't even make sense
all right podcast question number one
bill he talked about wanting to have a
kid now now that you're getting older
I'm just curious to know if you would
want him or her to hear your podcasts
considering you condone things like
revenge
I love how people don't listen to me I
don't condone revenge
I've said that on every podcast but I do
find the stories interesting and I will
comment and laugh at the [ __ ] that you
did I don't condone what Scarface did
but I can enjoy him shooting up people
in the end of the movie you know anyway
so he but anyways the boy this guy heard
it maybe I may be out you know maybe I
wasn't clear about what I was saying so
anyways the way he heard it is basically
I condone things like revenge and he
said ie busting a nut on your ex face to
make her feel like a [ __ ] for cheating
on you I'm not criticizing you I'm
sincerely interested in knowing if
having a child will change your
perception on things because as I close
in on 40 I'm feeling the same way
wanting to finally have a kid and it
makes me consider if I should adjust my
moral compass beforehand because I would
want my son or daughter to have me as a
decent role model your situation a
little more precarious in that your
future ten-year-old son could find an
old copy of bilborough's Greatest Hits
and hear how his father thinks that
coming a girl's hair is the best
prescription for heartbreak keep up the
good work
ah alright Michael this is how I view
this type of [ __ ]
for me to actually think about anything
that I'm saying on this podcast about
actually having a child that I don't
even have is the quickest way of making
these podcasts horrifically unfunny I
actually I have major problems with
parents and how once they have kids they
all of a sudden start acting like
they're not the [ __ ] frat boy date
rapist that they used to be and not only
do they act that way they want everyone
else to behave that way too because they
knocked up the chick that they're with
and it's like dude I didn't knock up my
curl okay I'm still having a good
[ __ ] time you know what I mean so if
my you know I don't know why don't I do
the rest of this pod does this moment
right now like my future ten-year-old
son is actually listening to the
archives hey son what's going on it's
your dad
I hope I didn't [ __ ] up the first ten
years of your life listen son if you're
taking anything that I say on these
podcasts remotely seriously I've
completely failed as a parent and I want
you to go outside and fall on a [ __ ]
lawn dart because I'm going to start
over again and I'm going to make another
kid
and I'm going to teach him to learn how
to [ __ ] take a joke now you know I
got halfway through that just got
[ __ ] creepy I just told my future kid
to kill himself yeah with a toy that has
been banned now to be honest with you
know I never I never think about what
you're asking me do I swear to God is
the formula for not becoming funny you
know that's what comedians do is they
get older they have kids and all of a
sudden they stop cursing onstage and
they say want to be a role model and
that's when [ __ ] just starts going
downhill and you know you want to start
doing family movies you know and I'm not
doing that
okay I'm a comedian nothing I say should
be taken seriously and if you take it
seriously that's not my problem
even if you are my kid I'm be honest
with my kid you know I mean how people
like trying to shelter their kid and
tell them that there's a Santa Claus and
everything like that and you know
yeah I don't know about that like if
somebody does something really weird and
then my kids like why did somebody why
did that person do that I'd be like you
know what son because most people are
comes you know I know it's a harsh
reality and enjoy your coloring year's
Sun because it's only going to get worse
are we going to get worse all right bill
listening to okay bill listening to the
newly discovered podcast you all this is
the guy you know what this guy I mean I
wouldn't say this guy for this this
right here not his whole email but this
email right here I think this guy turns
douchebag of the of the [ __ ] week
because he goes you should charge for
your podcast and up the production value
or just leave them as they are just
don't keep mentioning that they're free
like other podcasters do it's a bit
douchey when you do that you know what
why don't you go [ __ ] yourself how about
you do that is that douchey if I tell
you that you [ __ ] [ __ ] don't tell me
what to do in this [ __ ] podcast it is
free I don't need to do this [ __ ] gonna
tell me how the [ __ ] I'm supposed to do
these alright so don't [ __ ] yourself on
your first paragraph but because I'm
such a sweetheart I'll read the rest of
it the rest of it you don't [ __ ] with
you're a douche in your first paragraph
ah bill so with the Vinny call you to
come and I kind of assume you are a
drummer like me and with the headphone
comment drummer headphones got to be
right I've got to be right so if you are
a drummer and listen through headphones
listen to Steve Steve of seven days then
in parentheses it says stings filled
with gold oh they did they did a cover
of that yeah I don't know if you guys
listen to the podcast but that's I'm
kind of into I've been starting to buy
records started buying them again and
find like some concept albums and that
you know those all those great old
albums so just a great somebody says I
somebody brought something on the
internet where they were just they were
bitching about music today and they said
something to the effect of how you know
how bum they work because people today
don't want to hear good music
I just think that's such a hilarious
comment people today yeah they don't
want to hear good music oh yeah that's
that's exactly what it is it has nothing
to do with the deregulation of media in
the early 1980s which allowed [ __ ]
five guys to buy all the [ __ ] radio
stations and to run everyone exactly
like the other one thus limiting the
amount of music they can get on the
radio that's not what it is
it's that people then they don't want to
hear good music is that good music you
shut that off mister I don't want to
hear that I want to hear something awful
I don't want to hear good music you know
it's funny that's the cleaning lady to
the outside of the door and she thinks I
can't hear and I know she's listening to
me ranting in here debating whether or
not to come in here or not I know you're
out there
um John I just freaked her up I kind of
freaked me out too because I realized
that technically I really am NOT talking
to anybody um what was I talking about
oh yeah the music I think there's plenty
of music out there you just have you get
you set to find it it's on the internet
now and possibly on satellite radio and
if you don't have satellite radio that's
one of the most underrated things ever
it's [ __ ] incredible and I'm I'm
getting it put in my car because I've
run a few cars recently and they've had
satellite ready radio in it and that's
where the good music is that's where the
funny radio shows are that's where it's
that when it comes to radio man it's
[ __ ] great and people curse on the
radio which I enjoy and if I had a
ten-year-old son I'd let let him listen
to those words because I always heard
him from the day I was walking around I
heard him and look at me I turned out
fine and I did to stop laughing I did
pay my [ __ ] taxes I'm not hurting
anybody um anyways overrated underrated
uh overrated
this guy says Sonic Youth dot dot dot
really you know what I don't know why
they're the ones you're saying runaway
train about the kids who runaway runaway
chair they were coming back following
selves assaulted something yak
Paul Simon dot dot dot I want to shove
an African drum up his ass is he black
now okay listen to any Paul Simon album
in the late 80s early 90s you ever think
he was just trying to expand as an
artist and he was working with different
musicians and he went outside of America
you know it's not like he went out there
with a FUBU [ __ ] tracksuit on when he
played with them notice I said FUBU
staying in ties with the early 90s was
bubu wasn't I was at mid nineties you
know Jesus Christ who did he black now
he standing next to a black guy he's
still wearing those Wrangler jeans those
awful hair plugs BB King another guy
says it's overrated he's been milking
the legend status for so long he can't
he can't even play a chord C u2's
rattling hum dude I got to agree with
you on that one BB King I think yeah I
think he might be a little overrated the
guy can't play a chord he does play
nicely
but if he's noticed it's not a lot of
black people going up to see him I think
it's a bunch of white people who think
he's good that was one of the most
ignorant [ __ ] things I'll ever say
and that really made me laugh you know
and that guy who sent me the email I
didn't mean that so in the future or my
ten-year-old son
hears it is I you know he's gonna know
Jesus Christ why would you put that in
my [ __ ] head I never think [ __ ] like
that and that's how you know if you
think about ramifications you're never
going to be funny hey what if I say this
won't that hurt someone in the crowd and
then the moment to set it is gone and
it's over five bad shows tonight I'm
gonna [ __ ] blame you they like that
all right
underrated the Mayfield for myles
kennedy i have no idea who that is
i'm going to look that up and roy
orbison he's one of those guys who's
overrated and underrated i think is
underrated with the average listener and
he's overrated when you just talk about
him about his seven octave
hey I don't know he really has an
amazing range with his voice but I don't
like the sound of it is that like
sacrilegious what are some of the songs
he sings like pretty woman kill yourself
he looks like a lesbian alright
underrated uh the sluttiness of college
chicks
I don't care well sing the Roy Orbison
he died out of nowhere man I had a heart
attack that's one of those guys when he
dies of a heart attack you really look
at his face it's like yeah I can see the
heart attack
he had that blue cheese double chin
underrated the sluttiness of college
chicks I don't care where you went to
college if you lived any if you lived
away at school and weren't getting laid
once a week something must be wrong with
your dick this is over exaggerating a
bit that's one of my favorite
expressions I think I've ever read
over-exaggerating I'm trying to do the
math on what the [ __ ] that means so if
you said if you lived away at school and
we're getting laid at least once a week
if you weren't getting laid at least
once a week some must be wrong with your
dick but that statement is is over
exaggerated over it says does that mean
you're not exaggerating does that mean
you get laid one-and-a-half times a week
you've tagged someone and fingerblast
someone else I really don't do sex jokes
oh really that that makes me
uncomfortable
ah but this is over exaggerating a bit
but still it is ridiculous I went to a
small Catholic college but you would
know about the stories I got from my
dorm room a couple beers some can't even
read this do you guys you guys like
against using the space bar a couple
beers some dim dorm room lighting and
slow jam play lifts off your laptop and
you were in business most of the time it
didn't even matter if your roommates
were there I once had my roommate wake
up to this [ __ ] sitting on my face
riding it like a unicycle alright we're
going to stop there okay I got it dude
you're getting late
Jesus Christ you know what that's
actually true I never lived at college
but I definitely hooked up with college
girls and I actually hooked up with a
girl in the top bunk in a girl in a
roommate Sally was in the bottom bunk
but was awake I never try to [ __ ]
respectively for Spain as a respective
kind of way it doesn't really work
especially when you use a word you can't
even pronounce respectively does that
even is that even a word
alright overrated adding Y to the end of
guys names unless you're playing
stickball in the schoolyard or your
grandma calls to wish you a happy
birthday if you're over the age of 18
you're a man and should not be referred
to as Joey or Danny or any other
[ __ ] name ending in Y I'm hoping you
would want to punch the first guy walks
up and says hey Billy what's up it's
[ __ ] you're a man you should go buy
a man's name you know what that's
exactly right I actually when I first
came into this business I went by build
bar and I thought it was too short and
too difficult to say so for like five
years I went by Billy bar and even
though it's slowed better with my last
name anytime anybody called me that it
just it it didn't feel right it was just
like let's think I was some like New
Jersey they have a way making it sound
all right on New York guys but it's just
I just felt like a little kid like I
should have been sitting there with my
brown sack lunch and after I I don't
know how Billy Crystal does it so I
would have to agree with you on that one
all right I think that's it I think
that's it for the podcast I want to
thank everyone for listening this week
it's a little bit on the short side but
I know it's weird I'm up in San
Francisco and I got a gig tonight and
I'll before I even do the gay I want to
thank everybody for coming out on a
Monday night I know it's uh you know
it's a work night for you guys you
working hard then type of [ __ ] so listen
to this before you come up to my show
I'm going to try out this new chunk and
I'm probably going to bomb but uh
definitely going to give you your
money's worth I really appreciate
everybody who showed up
or who's going to show up or if this is
the next day who has showed up Jesus
Christ they'll get to the point and next
week I'm going to be at the not this
upcoming weekend the following weekend
last weekend of March I'm going to be at
the house comedy in st. Louis all the
informations on Bill burr calm and
anything else oh and I'm going to be on
the Opie and Anthony show
um when this I got I got an Atlantic
City date governor what is the [ __ ]
day hold on a second I got to figure
this out
I need a calendar god damn it hang on a
sec you know this podcast was going
pretty smooth up until this point this
is just garbage time you can hang up
right now
North listen to this alright the Trump
marina gig is on April 4th all right so
that's a Saturday so Friday the 3rd 2nd
1st the 1st 2nd and 3rd at least time
when we go I'm gonna be on the Opie and
Anthony show I'm going back into New
York and I'm going to visit my my good
friends Opie and Anthony and they always
hilarious
little Jimmy Norton and I'm really
excited to get back there spend umber
one thing that I miss about living in
New York I [ __ ] love doing that show
and it is on XM satellite radio because
satellite radio is the [ __ ] XM 202 and
I'll be doing taping an uninformed
episode with Joe DeRosa and and that is
it I think that's it I'll also be an
electronic theater in Chicago Illinois
on April 3rd look at me
zig zagging across the [ __ ] country
all right and that is it you guys all
have yourself a good week and God bless
the United States of America say no to
the Amero and the North American Union
and microchips god bless you